みんな聞いてくれ
帰る方法が…
なくなった！
大事件だ！
大事件なんだ！
えーただいま、いま六本木にいます
今日ちょっと撮影してて
朝から、朝から撮影してて
事務所についたのが23時
それから飯とか食ってなんかしてると
24時になってしまいました
新幹線がねえ！
というわけで新幹線がないんですけど
僕なんかほんとに今回ばかりは
どうしても静岡に帰りたくて
どうしようかなと思ったんですけども
タクシーで帰ることにしました！
UUUMから静岡の僕の家まで帰ると
何円するのか調べていこうと思います
もうタクシーの運転手さんに
静岡まで行っていいですか
というのを言ったら
いいよって言われたんで大丈夫です
では、静岡駅までお願いします
（運転手さん：あっ、はい、お願い致します）
【はじめ会釈】
すいません長くて
（あっ、いえいえ）
0:08 スタートでーす
今ちょっとタクシーで静岡に帰ってまして
本当申し訳ない
でもなんか気になんない？
事務所からお家まで
何円かかるのかって、車で
怖いよね
（渋滞に遭ってたんで）
あーなるほど
（渋谷の駅の方から通ってきたら）
（いいかなって思って来たんですけども）
はい
（そうしましたら今日に限って今工事してて）
あらまあ
（ちょっと）
（あの、どっちも進まなかった感じなんですけど）
あーなるほどなるほど
（できたらあの）
あ～やったーありがとうございます
値引き！
そうなんスよ…
（そうですね）
値引きは無くても大丈夫です
（ではこの辺に停めてます）
はい、すいません(眠たそう)
（はーい）
すいません、お願いします
（お客さん、タバコとか大丈夫ですか？）
あー全然大丈夫です
あっ、やったー
【はじめ焦る】
（ふふふっww）
こっからすね、でも
（そうですね）
こっから盛り上がるとこっすね
（ちょっとすいません）
いえいえ…
（機械：料金は72120円です）
（はい…）
ははっww
（ちょっと動かしてもいいですか？）
はい
7万か…
なんかけど思ったほどでしたね
そうですよね
7万すか…(小声)
（機：カードをどうぞ）
はい
（機：ICカードの場合は暗証番号を…）
（私の最高記録です）
最高記録ですか！
（はい、またよろしくお願いします）
すいません、ありがとうございました
帰り遠いと思うんでお気を付けて
（はい、ありがとうございます）
すいません、ありがとうございました
（それにコーヒーもごちそうさまです）
いえいえ、そんなとんでもないです
すいません、本当にありがとうございました
（いえいえ、ありがとうございます）
ありがとうございました
（お気を付けて）
はーい
ありがとうございます、おやすみなさーい
（ありがとうございまーす）
【ED】